Tom Anderson, better known online as MySpace
Tom, was, for a brief period in the early
2000s, arguably the most popular man on the
internet.
Boasting over 200 million friends at the apex
of MySpace’s popularity, Tom was everybody
who signed up to use the site’s first, but
hopefully not only, friend.
So what is he doing now and why was he everyone’s
friend?
To answer the latter, well, if you want to
be everyone’s friend, helping to found the
website is a good way to make that happen.
Created in 2003, MySpace was a direct response
to Friendster, an early social networking
site that has since faded into obscurity,
though at its peak had several million members
and was turning down dozens of millions of
dollar buyout offers from companies like Google.
In early 2003, while working for a company
called eUniverse, Tom lamented that Friendster
took a heavy-handed approach to so-called
“Fakester” profiles belonging to people
pretending to be fictional characters, or
satirical accounts from people pretending
to be celebrities, etc.
Tom felt Friendster’s policy of summarily
deleting these was a mistake, reasoning that
the internet of all places should be a forum
people felt comfortable expressing themselves
in any way they chose.
In a later interview, Tom waxed poetic about
the nature of personal identity, musing, “Identity
is provisional.
Who we are is whom we choose to be at any
given moment, depending on personality, whim,
temperament or subjective need.”
With this in mind, Tom approached his friend
and eUniverse boss, Chris DeWolfe, with a
simple proposal- launch a site that basically
aped everything Friendster was doing, but
not be as stuffy or uptight about users calling
themselves Noir Angel or Dark Blade 69 or
taking on any persona they chose.
DeWolfe agreed with Tom that this could potentially
be a lucrative venture and the pair quickly
set about finding a name for the site.
According to Tom, early ideas for what to
call the website included both YoPeeps.com
and Comingle.com, before DeWolfe remembered
that he had previously acquired the domain
MySpace.com from a data storage company YourZ.com,
Inc. that had gone out of business.
As for why MySpace took off and the then wildly
popular Friendster went the way of the Dodo,
the ultimate success of the site is generally
largely attributed to a combination of good
timing, the duo’s business acumen, their
experience and resources in the field, and
plain old dumb luck.
As an example of the latter, when coding the
website, they committed a cardinal sin in
software engineering in forgetting to properly
sanitize their inputs.
Or, in other words, they accidentally allowed
users to insert HTML tags and the like into
their pages.
A huge potential security risk, this nonetheless
meant that users could customise their profile
pages in almost any way they wanted- people
loved this (at first).
When this snafu was discovered, while steps
were taken to mitigate some of the security
problems this could have introduced, Tom and
DeWolfe came to appreciate how allowing users
to do this fit into the site’s ethos of
letting people express themselves any way
they wanted.
As a result, rather than fully fixing the
bug, in a great example of textbook software
engineering ethos, they rebranded the bug
a feature.
As for the duo’s business acumen and experience,
they not only were able to create a system
that performed much faster than Friendster’s
notoriously slow site, but also embarked on
a 17 city nightclub tour to woo hot women
to their platform via having professional
photographers take free glamor shots of the
ladies in exchange for said women joining
up.
Naturally, where attractive women are online,
the men of the species inevitably flock like
the salmon of Capistrano.
On top of that, they traveled around attempting
to get bands to sign up on the platform, ultimately
convincing over 5,000 such groups to join
up in the early marketing blitz days.
These bands, in turn, encouraged their fans
to check out their MySpace pages.
As DeWolfe put it at the time, “We want
to be the MTV of the Internet”.
Towards this end, they even eventually implemented
features to allow musicians to upload and
sell their music through the site.
(This strong connection to music is still
one of the ways MySpace survives as a surprisingly
well trafficked site even to this day, ranking
in around the 3800th most popular site in
the world and around the 1900th most popular
in the United States.
While those might seem like unimpressive numbers
to the uninitiated, that likely means MySpace
is still getting several million unique visitors
per month.
Which, well…)
On top of those in-person member acquisition
methods, the pair also leveraged access to
their day job at eUniverse’s 20+ million
strong email address list to promote the site.
That said, the biggest initial marketing payoff
came from wooing several of Friendster’s
most prominent users over to MySpace.
The biggest of these was the now somewhat
infamous social media personality Tila Tequila,
who noted of her social media fame at the
time, “There’s a million hot naked chicks
on the Internet.
There’s a difference between those girls
and me.
Those chicks don’t talk back to you.”
At the time, Tequila had approximately 40,000
friends on Friendster.
Besides being fed up with how slow Friendster
was, Tequilla also kept getting in trouble
on the site for her risque photographs and
larger than life confrontational/controversial
public persona.
Reaching out to her, Tom and DeWolfe convinced
Tequila that she’d have no such problems
on their new social media site.
She, thus, jumped ship to the new platform.
Tequila’s impact on the site’s growth
was felt immediately and, soon after, other
major online personalities followed her lead.
As Tequila herself would later note in an
interview with Time magazine:
At that time no one was on there at all.
I felt like a loser while all the cool kids
were at some other school.
So I mass e-mailed between 30,000 and 50,000
people and told them to come over.
Everybody joined overnight.
Oft called “The Queen of MySpace”, during
the site’s heyday Tequila had around 1.5
million friends on the site, which, while
impressive, was nowhere near the 200+ million
Tom had during MySpace’ reign at the top.
And for those who missed out on that era,
despite Facebook being founded in 2004, from
about 2005 to 2008 MySpace was indeed on top,
including for a brief time in 2006 even becoming
the most visited site on the internet, edging
out Google for that honour.
And, amazingly, in 2008 MySpace generated
nearly a billion dollars in revenue, valued
at some $12 billion at that point.
(As an interesting aside, in February of 2005,
DeWolfe even turned down Mark Zuckerberg’s
offer to sell Facebook to MySpace for a mere
$75 million…
It’s also fascinating to note that Friendster
likewise turned down an offer to merge with
MySpace not long before Friendster’s ultimate
decline into oblivion.)
In any event, as to why Tom was automatically
added as a friend on MySpace, this was partially
a way to ensure everyone had a friend right
from the start but, much more importantly,
this was a way to introduce some of the friend
management features to newbies, like the “Top
8” which allowed users to sort their friends
in order of who they liked most.
As any of us who lived through it remembers,
this was a hugely popular feature that led
to an amazing amount of teenage angst and
drama.
Although users were free to immediately unfriend
Tom if they felt like it, most didn’t, making
him, for a brief window in the 2000s, one
of the most recognizable people online.
In regards to Tom’s now iconic profile picture,
Tom continues to use it across his current
very prominent social media profiles, despite
the picture being around a decade and a half
old at this point.
On Facebook- yes, we’re quoting a Facebook
post written by the co-founder of MySpace-
Tom noted that while his name Tom Anderson
is “pretty generic”, his MySpace profile
picture is so iconic that most internet savvy
people recognise it almost instantly.
Furthermore, in a tweet (and now we’re quoting
him from Twitter- some people just like to
watch the world burn), Tom replied more succinctly
to a fan asking why he still used the same
profile picture:
If I used a new profile picture it would break
the internet; my pic has been viewed more
than the mona lisa bitch
You might now be wondering if that’s actually
true.
Well, probably not, and definitely not if
you level the playing field to include digital
copies of the Mona Lisa.
However, if you restrict the sample-set to
the number of people who’ve seen the original,
physical Mona Lisa since the debut of Tom’s
profile pic, then, yes, though, as noted,
that’s hardly a level playing field.
Nevertheless, for reference, the Louvre gets
about 7-9 million visitors per year in modern
times.
Even if everyone who has gone in the 21st
century took a gander at the Mona Lisa while
there, that’s still at best maybe 120-ish
million people viewing the painting, which
doesn’t hold a candle to Tom’s profile
pic’s unique viewer numbers.
We do, however, like to think several hundred
years from now “The MySpace Tom smile”
is something that will be studied by historians,
with the profile pic featured at digital museums
the world over- no doubt a centerpiece of
internet history sections of the museums.
I mean, those perfect teeth, and the way his
eyes seem to follow you no matter what angle
you look at the picture from…
What’s he smiling about anyway?
Did someone make a joke?
Is he just naturally photogenic?
Who took the photo?
Adding to the mystery and presumably infuriating
future historians, Tom is quite secretive
about the origins of the photograph when asked.
In any event, beyond not wanting to “break
the internet”, a secondary reason that Tom
has never changed his profile picture is that
it looks almost nothing like him today.
You see, paradoxically for a man who once
had 200+ million online friends, Tom is a
pretty private person and he’s noted that
he’s very happy that the most well-known
photo of him in existence isn’t all that
representative of how he looks most of the
time.
In an interview with PetaPixel Tom further
explained: “I’m always amazed that someone
can recognize me from that picture.
Its kind of been a benefit that people don’t
really know what I look like…
I get recognized just enough for it to be
fun and not disruptive.”
Which is actually pretty genius and something
we’ve written about before when discussing
Daft Punk.
To summarize a point we made in that article,
Guy-Manuel de Homem-Christo and Thomas Bangalter
adopted their robotic alter egos early in
their career partly so that they could enjoy
fame without having to deal with the inevitable
downsides that come with it, such as being
constantly accosted by fans or followed by
the paparazzi.
This all brings us around to what Tom’s
up to now.
It turns out, Tom has a bit of an obsessive
personality about whatever he’s currently
doing, with those interests being quite diverse.
As he notes, “I’ve lived many lives, so
to speak.
At one time I was in a band (both as a singer
and guitar player) and that was all I did
every day.
If you knew me in college, you would have
assumed I was going to be an egghead professor….
I like change.
I like the idea that anything can happen…”
What he doesn’t reveal there is that before
all that, at the tender age of just 14, he
spent his days hacking, going by the name
Lord Flathead.
Most famously, he managed to hack into Chase
Manhattan Bank’s mainframe.
Not as exciting as movies depicting such things
make out, he reportedly managed this by simply
war dialing and then, when the system responded,
he was eventually able to guess an administrative
user name and password correctly.
Once in, beyond sharing this information with
a few dozen hacker friends, he also changed
a couple passwords to stop certain bank officials
from being able to access the system and,
at least according to a contemporary New York
Times article, created a few accounts of his
own, then left a message for bank officials
that he was going to start deleting financial
records unless they let him use the computer
for whatever he wanted…
Unsurprisingly, soon after there was an FBI
raid of some 23 homes in the San Diego area
where Tom lived.
Initially thinking they were about to make
some major hacker arrests, what the FBI found
was a bunch of young teens just playing around.
Because Tom was so young, the FBI and Chase
Manhattan Bank let him off with a simple slap
on the wrist- taking away his computer and
never returning it, as well as making him
promise to stop his black-hat hacking ways
lest he be arrested.
Much more recently, after spending four years
serving as the president of MySpace when NewsCorp
acquired the site for over a half a billion
dollars in 2005, Tom basically retired in
2009.
He even ceased using MySpace at that point,
posting on Facebook, “I don’t like using
it anymore… not a fan of what the new folks
have done with MySpace.”
(You and me both, Tom.)
At this point you might be wondering exactly
how much Tom made from selling his stake in
MySpace.
Well, this isn’t clear, with sources wildly
conflicting on the amount- quoting numbers
everywhere from a few million dollars to a
few hundred million.
Whatever the case, it’s safe to say even
if it was $0, thanks to his salary after the
NewsCorp acquisition- which included an initial
$30 million, two year contract- after Tom
walked away from the site, he hasn’t had
to worry about money.
Tom himself sheds a little light on the matter,
stating, “When MySpace sold, I made more
money than I could ever possibly need”.
Following his quasi-retirement, Tom notes
he spent a lot of time “learning about architectural
design.”
He goes on, “When I left the work world,
I started designing my dream house.
I dived into architecture and bought seven
vacant lots.
My plan was to build one house, move in, and
build the next.
If the next was better, I’d move in and
sell the previous one – so on and so forth”.
He designed and had built three homes before
his passions went another direction, which
leads us to present day in which Tom spends
most of his time with a different obsession-
travel photography.
While he does not sell his photos as, to quote
him, “that would just feel like work, which
I don’t want to do”, it’s still something
he pursues full time.
This is a profession he was inspired to start
after attending Burning Man in 2011.
In his own words:
I became friends with photographer Trey Ratcliff
and since I was going to hang out with him
at Burning Man, I decided to get a camera.
I didn’t really develop an interest until
I saw the photos I was getting.
In other words, I didn’t think “I want
to be a photographer.”
I just saw the photos that were coming out
of my camera and I was kind of blown away.
I was mystified why I was liking what I was
getting so much.
With most creative pursuits, I would struggle
for years and still not like the result.
With photography I was liking what I was producing
literally from day one.
Then gradually it just became a way of life
and now an intense passion…
I’ve divested myself of all other responsibility
so I can just travel and shoot.
Or to put it another way, like most of your
friends from MySpace who had way more friends
than you, he’s today spending most of his
time taking artsy photos for Instagram.
And, actually… wow.
Unlike most of those aforementioned former
MySpace friends, he’s got some pretty ridiculously
amazing shots over there, which can best,
I think, be described as Top Shelf Travel
Porn…
Nothing halfway, eh, Tom?